كشفت قضيه المسيره ام كيو 9 الامريكيه فوق
البحر الاسود عن اهميه الاستطلاعات الجويه
الامريكيه في مساعده اوكرانيا لمواجهه
الهجمات الروسيه
تركيز الولايات المتحده في المنطقه هو على
اوكرانيا ومساعدتها بما تحتاجه للدفاع عن
نفسها وقد سمعتنا نقول ان من حق اوكرانيا
ان تدافع عن نفسها ونحن لدينا الحق في
مساعدتها مع الاسره الدوليه هناك خريطه
وزعها الامريكيون عن الاجواء التي هاجمت
فيها المقاتله الروسيه المسيره الامريكيه
وكشفت انها كانت على مسافه تسمح لها
بالتقاط معلومات خاصه بالجيش الروسي في
جزيره القرم ومحيط البحر الاسود
بشان هذه المهمه كان من الممكن ان تكون
مخصصه للاستعلام الالكتروني فهي تراقب
اشارات الراديو والاشارات
الالكتروماغناطيسيه في هذه المنطقه وهذه
المسيره تحلق على ارتفاع شاهق ولديها ايضا
قدرات مناظ ير
ربما يفسر هذا الامر قرار القوات الروسيه
باعتراض المسيره الامريكيه العاليه
التقنيه
واجبارها على السقوط في المياه الدوليه
لكنها لن تكون نهايه المطاف بالنسبه الى
الامريكيين فالاستطلاعات الجويه بما فيها
الاستعانه بالاقمار الاصطناعيه هي ركيزه
اساسيه في دفاعات الاوكرانيين ضد الجيش
الروسي الذي يحاول التقدم في اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان الامر فائق الاهميه فاوكرانيا
لديها قدرات محدوده للاستعلامات والمراقبه
خلف خطوط العدو وما يفعله الروس وليست لدى
الاوكرانيين اقمار اصطناعيه او طائرات
عاليه التحليق
يحاول الروس الان الوصول الى حطام المسيره
في اعماق البحر الاسود لكنها لن تفيدهم في
شيء كثير لان برامج التشغيل تم تدميرها من
قبل الامريكيه كما ان الامريكيين سيتابعون
مساعده الاوكرانيين في الاستطلاعات
ويرسلون اليهم قريبا جدا رزمه جديده من
الاسلحه والعتاد الامريكي هي الغنمه
العربيه